be strategic about who you book as
guests a lot of people try to come out
the gate and get their biggest guest
when the right answer is get 10 guests
first in that are not as big giving
yourself time to get good at
interviewing and then you start layering
the bigger guests you can get I'm way
better at hosting a podcast today than I
was the first 100 I did because you just
get reps you get to understand I like
struggled cutting people off I still do
it you have no idea that if you're gonna
be good at it or good by your standard
and then the key is about post-producing
the podcast into as many pieces of
content that are smaller in a Tick Tock
YouTube social work so it's almost like
the podcast also has to produce creative
that brings awareness you do the Big
Show to make the small pieces of content
the small pieces of content bring
awareness to the Big Show and it's just
good morning anything like that people
have a sense of what they want to make
people just wanted to be successful too
fast